we're on the fractions on the number  line exercise on Khan Academy and they  asked us to move the orange dot to  three-fourths on the number line change  the number of divisions to create tick  marks on the number line so let's see  what's going on here so I have the space  from zero to one on the number line if I  want to move it to three-fourths what I  would first want to do is divide the  space between zero and one into fourths  into four equal sections so I would want  to have four divisions here and there  you have it four divisions I typed in  the number four and they have four equal  divisions one two three four and so this  is going to be a fourth that's another  fourth that's another fourth and that's  another fourth what we care about is  three-fourths so once again that's one  fourth this would be another fourth  getting us to two fourths and then this  would be another fourth getting us to  three fourths so there you have it that  is three fourths on the number line